We spend a lot of time and a lot of
money protecting the edges of our
network with firewalls, intrusion
prevention, and other types of security
systems. But these security systems on
the perimeter of our network are not
protecting the systems that are inside
of our network. And of course, we have
many employees in our organization that
have access to all of the systems that
we might have on the protected internal
network. Because of this, we have to
consider that some of these employees
could potentially be a threat that's on
the inside of our network. This is not
just a threat where users are writing
down their password on a yellow sticky
and putting it underneath their
keyboard. This might be a case where
someone inside of your organization who
has access to large amounts of data
across many sensitive systems may
somehow become the attacker from the
inside of your network. These employees
know where all of the sensitive data is
stored. They know the security methods
that are used to protect that data. And
they know how to remove or copy that
data without causing any type of
security alarms on your network. And
these are people that are coming to work
every day who have constant access to
this very sensitive data.
This may not be just disgruntled
employees who are part of an insider
threat. This may be a directed threat
towards your employees. We have
documented cases where the attackers are
recruiting people inside of these
companies to be able to give them access
to systems or to give them data. For
example, we have cases where ransomware
has been found inside of organizations,
but the ransomware was put there by the
employees themselves. The attackers are
able to use Bitcoin or some type of
cryptocurrency to be able to entice
employees to plug in a USB drive and
walk away. The ransomware software
starts automatically. It then starts
encrypting all of these systems and the
attacker ultimately earns millions of
dollars from this single attack. This is
why many organizations are updating
their security best practices to better
protect all of the data that's on the
inside of the network. These
organizations are also updating some of
their other practices such as backups to
ensure that they always have a good copy
of this data.